this is the fourth turning you're
familiar with the fourth training right
fourth turning no no don't worry about
so you know it's it's the this the four
seasons Every 80 years there's yes okay
yeah every 20 years you have a cycle
yeah all right so for those that are not
familiar forget there's a historian
straws how generational Theory yeah and
so you've got these the the different
seasons within it there's four periods
they're about 20 20 years long each this
is the What's happen what we're seeing
right now with uh this what you refer to
as the Paradigm Shift right like your
mom was counterculture opposing the
major corporations now the the
generation today the Young Generation is
pro-corporate Amazon's got their black
lives matter you know Netflix all these
big there's a video game I can't
remember what video game it was it
opened up and it said black lives matter
the the the attacking the establishment
has become the establishment in a very
weird way but this is why I say it's the
fourth turning
when you had a youth you had a culture
of young people growing up being told to
fight the power you know fight the
system fight the man then when they all
become adults and inherit the power
their worldview is still fight the power
so now they're in power yeah telling
everyone to fight the power which leads
us to the fourth season the fourth
turning the great conflict is if you
take an entire generation and tell them
the system is broken and corrupt and you
must fight back they inherit the power
and then start ripping it to shreds and
gutting it
you're gonna get a crisis imagine you're
you're FL you're driving in a car and
some dudes actively like punching holes
in the floor and trying to you know Jam
things against your drive shaft or
something you're gonna crash but I think
if we live in a flourishing fully
functioning Society then we actually
raise people who are critical thinkers
who are able to you know shed their old
self and see uh you know a new truth or
or change their perspective as they get
older but like just like my mom did and
you know sure and now what did she
really well I think she did you know I
think she had a certain way of viewing
politics
um in the last five years that she's
certainly changed I mean maybe as a
byproduct of like being you know me
being her son and my younger brother
like caught her on like a work Zoom
meeting like yeah so everybody knows
that uh you know that's so it's all just
media narratives and it's like whoa whoa
mama mom you can't come on like this is
not for Zoom calls it is it is though my
son told me this so it really is it's
like you know uh Hard Times make strong
men strong men strong strong men make
good times good times weak men weak men
Hard Times Etc et cetera because you
have this period of like you know look
the Boomers man were they they were like
hippies and protesters and now they're
all leading these big corporations and
what happened you know what I mean how
how have you seen SLC Punk
yeah movie have you seen SLC punkian no
oh come on you guys what's it about it's
about this guy in Salt Lake City he's a
punk and then it ends with him like
wearing a suit and okay like at a
certain point people accept the
establishment and you know it's it's
really interesting to see how
Generations play a role in this the
children of the Boomers the echo Boomers
or the Millennials I like that word echo
boomer people people don't call
Millennials Echo Boomers though uh they
inherited a lot of the anger and rage of
the fight the man after the system from
their Boomer parents so they grow up
with that instilled completely in them
and then when they inherit the system
the moment they do they start doing all
sorts of wacky broken f.bs yeah but so
here's my question is if everything that
you're saying about like why
why is fighting the system now
supporting Joe Biden like where did burn
you know where did Bernie go
how did that like revolutionary movement
get completely hijacked and out like the
wool is over everybody's eyes or are
people actually awake to this and it's
just our media is far removed from the
way that you know everyone's like wait a
minute dude collectivism they they're I
I don't know I don't know it's a weird
comp it's I think it's an amalgam of the
the generation assumes the power and
becomes the The Establishment while
telling everyone to fight The
Establishment not really it's them and
so then they target the not
establishment like Republicans have
States that's what they have they
control what is it 36 States or
something like that that's not that the
power Paradigm to a certain extent I
mean it's powerful having that many
sides if they get I think two more
States or whatever then they can have a
constitutional convention but for the
most part in this country universities
movies video games Federal level
politics social media too social media
it's all left it's all Progressive and
that's what that's what ultimately
compels people to make decisions in
their reality like government is one
thing thing and you make a very
concerted you know decision very like
you go to the polls to vote for this
person because I ideologically think
this but in terms of like I have a
friend who I'm not going to name
similarly to why you wouldn't but he has
a wedding
of his his actually his best best
friend's brother in Canada right and
it's coming up and it's like should I
get vaccinated just to go to the wedding
because my buddy's going to be sad if I
don't and everybody at that wedding is
going to say where is he you know oh
he's he's not here because he doesn't
have the vaccine he couldn't get over
the Border social pressure and so then
it's social it's social pressure that's
compelling you to make a medical
decision and that's that's the problem I
have with it you know and that and and
that specific subject like
you gotta talk to your doctor man like
this this he did it and yeah it's doctor
well I'm not going to say what it says
he made his decision and and that but
that's what I told him all his friends
were saying something different did he
end up going
um I think what's gonna happen and I
don't want to say too much because I'm
not sure
he's gonna try to go without the you
know situation
[Laughter]
um and see what happens your doctor
might try man like yeah like look you
you talk to a doctor and they might
actually tell you you might be surprised
I can't believe there's so many people
who don't trust their doctors to be
completely honest exactly well here's
the amount of people that are telling
that individual yo like I can't believe
that you would do that you know because
it's a medical personal medical decision
that he's making and it's becoming this
like you're a bad person because you
think because you're doing that yeah
when they talk about it it's like the
collective oh what about everybody else
with this genocide thing splitting
people into groups I was thinking about
the vaxxed and the non-vaxxed as opposed
to the pronouns
it's not just maggots since like what
you know liberals or whatever did you
get the vaccine yeah what vaccine for
what okay so tongue-in-cheek there's a
funny crossover there between like the
granola major lefties who are anti-vaxx
for a certain reason right
yeah exactly and so like it's a weird
like you know the Marianne Williamson
supporters oh people who want to live
naturally and then the people that
actually are afraid of the vaccine are
completely different types anti-vaxxers
were lefties they left Libertarians man
this is what I can't stand when I go on
political Compass memes on Reddit you
ever see that's a great subreddit by the
way it's really funny political Compass
memes because they they wreck on
everybody but they keep claiming the
libertarian left is antifa and woke and
I'm like that's not what the libertarian
left is the woke antifa left are
authoritarians who want to beat people I
mean there was a video that was posted
by Ford Fisher where there were guys
outside of like a medical it was like a
medical facility and they were anti-mask
they were like don't wear masks and
antifa shut up and started beating them
for not following State guidelines that
is not left libertarian left
Libertarians are like Marion Williamson
they insult her they called her the
woo-woo Crystal lady and she was like I
don't have crystals but you wanna you
wanna know what left libertarian is it
is the hippies who are like I.E tree
bark because it cured my my skin rash or
whatever like they're the hippies the
weirdo the Crystal wearings and and look
you know Luke we we love Luke we love
but he wears crystals too and he's like
your bones are made of crystal hydroxy
appetite your bones are made of graphene
the point is the point is
protarians are these people and and the
reason why they're adamantly opposed is
for personal decision reasons for the
most part but they get mocked as kooky
and crazy and what's funny is whenever I
bring up to I was like I was talking a
lefty friend of mine about Lefty
conspiracies and of course I mentioned
Russia gate and Ukraine getting all the
stuff and they're like well I don't know
man well we'll see that that's that
that's still out uh you know we'll see
what happens for the Mueller report to
drop yeah that's right no but they they
think that like Mueller will be revealed
and I'm like bro this is blue and
non-level stuff and then when I mention
the Lefty anti-vax people which were
like the the preeminent anti-vaxxers to
begin with they're like that's not true
those people aren't left-wing and I'm
like have you talked to them yeah they
are like as Lefty commune hippie flower
wearing as you can get yeah I mean it's
the same thing as the you know basically
like this weird Progressive support for
the police state and the intelligence
and it's like yo I was like I grew up
Auntie Bush anti-iraq war and as a
result result like anti-patriot act and
like
if like I were a true Lefty I'd be
supporting like the CIA right now like
what we we just watched about Southland
Tales you ever see it
no it was made and what year was it 2007
I don't know it's uh I think that's 2007
maybe 2006 and it was made by the guy
who did Donnie Darko and it's it's like
man you you guys gotta check this movie
out because it was written about a
future not too distant future where like
a nuclear war happens and then you've
got the Republicans who expand the
Patriot Act and the Democrats who have
like there's like the rise of the Neo
Marxist movement it's just really
fascinating to watch a movie from the
mid-2000s to see where the Liberals
thought our society would go because boy
were they wrong they were like the
Republicans were going to become you
know authoritarian expanding the
patriarch all that stuff and instead
what do we get we got the the the the
reality TV star real estate guy who
calls a woman horse face on Twitter like
certainly not the same he won't even
call in the the police to deal he won't
call in federal uh uh the Insurrection
act to deal with riots in that movie
they actually had like special forces
that were just shooting Marxist
like that's what these people thought
was gonna happen back then didn't happen
so I gotta ask in this movie was a
republican the president or was a
Democrat the president because Obama was
elected and then everyone was like oh my
gosh this is such a great thing I can't
remember
um I you know I'm not a big fan of the
movie to be a play honest I wasn't kind
of half watching it but it very much so
I was like it's got a ton of people like
Sarah Michelle Gellers in it Justin
Timberlake's in it the rocks in it weird
yeah yeah yeah Sean William Scott is
that his name he's in it yes the
idiocracy is definitely more more
prophetic than uh definitely yeah
idiocracy for sure you know it's
actually a great book that um it was
actually the last book that my dad ever
gave me before he passed yeah sorry but
it's it's significant in that respect
because it's called arrogance and it's
um it's Bernard Goldberg and it's it's
the sequel to bias but basically the
subhead for that book is rescuing
rescuing America from the media Elite I
mean that book what he predicts is you
know at that time in 2003 I think it was
written the Nightly News was getting
like 25 million views per broadcast and
he's like that is all going to crumble
and as it crumbles they'll be trying to
cling to control of the narrative and I
mean that's really what we're witnessing
I mean papers and you know the Nightly
News cable news it's all collapsing and
they have to just you know bump up
ratings I mentioned this six years ago
because uh the CEO of I said there was
going to be a bloodbath in digital he
was like it's not going to last and the
reason for it in my opinion was that a
lot of these digital news outlets were
doing this this trick called it was it
was called like
ads ad writes yeah ad rights assignments
something like that here's what they
would do they would you'd make a website
and we'll call it like super awesome
news.com or whatever well I shouldn't
actually say a word we'll call it you
know just
xnews.com wait that's actually probably
the name of a news organization okay
sure that is yeah hypothetical
non-existent news organization perfect
and let's say it gets 10 million views
per month they want to sell ads
but that's not a whole lot of traffic
yeah what they do is they license the
rights to views from click Farms so
you'll get you know a generic clip click
Farm website
that it will be like look at all these
pictures of you know Tom Cruise like
smiling and then it'll it'll say like 25
photos of crazy celebrity photos and
every time you click one it makes you
reload a new page because that turns one
person one article into 25 Pages 25
Pages dude it's like then here's what
happens the news organization then buys
the rights to those views and claims
there are views and all of a sudden now
this small news Outlet is getting a
hundred million views per month crazy so
so you know he was saying there's gonna
be a bloodbath I said
these companies don't realize they're on
the way out and their views even cable
TV are going down down down every day I
know we saw a big spike because of trump
but it's going down they're bleeding
it's consolidating a lot of ways but
it's it's like in order for the New York
Times survive it must create more
entropy around it than than you know in
the gates to put it this way
you might have a hundred million
subscribers to news outlets Nationwide
through all the different local Outlets
but most people are canceling those
subscriptions and the New York Times is
picking up only some of them everyone
else is getting news for free from Rage
Bay trash so the New York Times might
see its subscribers go up a few million
as the country sees total subscriptions
go down
they're going to lose their influence
they're going to make good money and
they're going to start thrashing about
violently once they realize they're
drowning it's like when you know when uh
someone starts suffocating and they
start just violently flailing and
freaking out that's what we're gonna see
from the media yeah but that's what we
are saying it's like if it's a boat
that's sinking and they're looking
around the ocean all desperately
scanning The Horizon they see far up in
the distance some chaos they zoom in on
it they copy it and then they blast it
out on the airwaves over and over and
over again it's this tiny dot in the far
distance in One Direction but they're
making it seem like it's the center
Focus exactly thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time